[Musik]
wie viel populismus steckt in den
sozialen netzen der deutschen auf der
internet-konferenz re publica haben wir
mit experten darüber gesprochen wie
populismus in sozialen medien
funktioniert wie hass kommentare
debatten beeinflussen und wer dafür
verantwortlich ist was gelöscht wird und
was nicht
sie erlebt es mittlerweile im wochentakt
wie in sozialen netzwerken populisten
und meinungsmacher ihre themen setzen
wie medien und öffentlichkeit verhindern
können sich dabei instrumentalisieren zu
lassen hat eva horn auf der re publica
analysiert das meinen teil meiner
aufgabe darin besteht auf twitter zu
gucken auf facebook zu gucken instagram
zu gucken
vor allen dingen auf dem darauf
gerichtet dass ich halt schaue was ist
irgendwie relevant für die redaktion was
könnte irgendwie für anderen ressorts
interessant sein und aber eben auch was
könnte vielleicht was sieht auf den
ersten blick interessant aus ist aber
vielleicht einfach eine kampagne und das
ist etwas womit ich mich viel
beschäftige und wo ich entsprechend hat
auch viel sehe
müssen wir da alle zu lernen dass wir
kampagnen erkennen ja auf jeden fall
musst du ja ganz drängt wir kennt man
kampagne
das ist ein immer so schwer zu sehen
also meistens zu halten wenn sehr viel
dann plötzlich bilder auftauchen die so
stark sind dass man wenn man den
persönlichen impuls hat und in sozialen
netzwerken unterwegs ist dass man die
sofort eilen will
und die kommen halt irgendwas im
politischen kontext beispielsweise
neonazis neonazis den clown marschieren
das sind halt so starke bilder
man sieht hier und man möchte diese
verteilen weil sie einen so abstoßend
man möchte sich halt sofort davon
distanzieren oder man möchte was dazu
sagen möchte ist irgendwie kommentieren
möchtest einordnen und das sind dann
halt so die momente wo ich als social
media redakteurin skeptisch werde weil
ich natürlich mir dann schon überlegen
bekommen denn diese ganzen bilder
er ist das vielleicht zufall dass die da
so an uniformiert aufgetreten sind oder
vielleicht am ende sogar nicht des
populismus rechtspopulismus so gibt es
auch als links populismus
populismus ist letztendlich eine form
der art und weise wie man ja in seine
debatten geht oder wie man irgendwie
dinge versucht zu verkaufen wenn ich das
bewerbungs wort mal benutzen darf
natürlich gibt es auch links populismus
ich würde aber dringend davon abraten
links und rechtspopulismus
gleichzusetzen
was kann jeder einzelne besser machen
nutzerinnen und nutzer sollten gucken
dass sie sich halt nicht im ersten
empörung aus reflex rechen geben sondern
erstmal ein bisschen überlegen was sie
da eigentlich gerade teilen wollen
nutzerinnen und nutzer sollten vor allen
dingen aufpassen dass sie nicht immer
nur hass und negative botschaften
verbreiten
tatsächlich gibt es im netz sehr viel
positives sehr viel schön dass man kann
die positives feedback geben
man kann natürlich auch versuchen die
mehr diversität reinzubringen
tatsächlich ist es ne eine unfassbare
quelle auch an diversität an
unterschiedlichen ansichten und das ist
tatsächlich so was was ich immer alle
nur ganz toll raten kann sind halt nicht
nur darauf zu versteifen dass man
meinetwegen zehn weißen deutschen
medienschaffenden auf twitter erfolgt
sondern einfach noch mal ein bisschen
druck weil der dass der blickwinkel
sicher weiß haben verstehen vielen dank
von spiegel online
[Musik]
wie es populisten durch hass kommentare
und gezielte hasskampagne neue facebook
gelingt gesellschaftliche debatten zu
beeinflussen hat philipp kreisel in der
studie hass auf knopfdruck
herausgefunden
ich bin für die preise und ich mache
ehrenamtliche daten aller lösungen für
die katastrophe ich bin hier und die
kann es mit tropen ich bin hier gibt es
zurzeit ende 2016
und dort haben sich ganz viele leute
zusammengeschlossen die die
diskussionskultur im internet verbessern
wollen und was wir uns halt gefragt
haben war wieso ist einmal so viel hass
in den kommentarspalten warum nimmt das
so stark über hand was wir uns dann
angeguckt haben ist wir haben uns über
einen ganzen monat hinweg ganz viele
kommentarspalten genauer angeguckt und
haben die daten dieser kommentarspalten
ausgewertet ich habe dafür über die über
die facebook entwickler schnittstelle
die interaktions daten heruntergeladen
zum beispiel wie viele kommentare es gab
weder kommentiert hat und wie viele
likes und werde vor allem auch mit likes
sich eingemischt haben die in die
debatten was dabei rauskam ist das so
eine ganz ganz kleine minderheit
für die allermeisten dieser likes und
kommentare verantworten ist accounts die
dort aktiv waren waren eben auch nicht
normale accounts sollen das waren
besonders rechte account also dass da
ist also ein sehr starkes
ungleichgewicht gewesen zugunsten dieser
sehr sehr rechten accounts besonders
aktiv war zb accounts die vorher mit
inhalten der identitäten bewegung
interagiert haben die auch vom
verfassungsschutz beobachtet wird
und da steckt eine strategie dahinter
was wir festgestellt haben ist das in
geheimen gruppen oder in geheimen chats
sich die rechtsextremen absprechen und
sich auf auf negative zum beispiel
einigen was sie was sie jetzt genau
pushen wollen und dann gehen sie in die
kommentarspalten oder auf twitter und
versuchen diese sachen besonders
hervorzuheben und besonders aufzuteilen
und besonders auch zu leiten damit dann
die algorithmen der sozialen medien
denken okay das ist anscheinend
interessiert an scheint viele leute dann
wird es weiter oben angezeigt womit wir
ja so ein bisschen bei der problematik
sind das eben dinge als thema oder als
debatte wahrgenommen werden die es
vielleicht gar nicht sind oder falsch
sind
wie ist da der gerade zum populismus
also wie schätzen sie das ein
wir hatten eine eine analyse gemacht
auch im januar letzten jahres am
holocaust gedenktag
und da wurde dann zum beispiel das
narrativ gepusht dass wir das warehouse
gedenkakt doch gar nicht mehr so wichtig
ist und dass das eigentlich nur von den
eliten dass wir an den holocaust
gedenken
und dafür wird man hat versucht den
eindruck zu erwecken dass dass der
holocaust gedenktag im volk gar keinen
rückhalt mehr hat was natürlich nicht
stimmt also ganz viele leute
beschäftigen sich mit dem thema
das ist eine sehr große gefahr dass dann
durch solche kampagnen tatsächlich leute
beeinflusst werden und denken okay wir
lassen das jetzt mit der
erinnerungskultur
das ist das wäre also ein sehr großer
schaden
[Musik]
auf der re publica haben wir den
filmemacher hans blog getroffen er hat
sich mit content moderatorin in manila
beschäftigt die in unseren sozialen
netzwerken dafür verantwortlich sind was
gelöscht wird und was nicht mein name
ist hans blog ich habe zusammen mit note
riesewieck den dokumentarfilm bezwingers
gemacht im letzten jahr der vor allem
das erste mal einen einblick gibt in
eine uns sonst verschlossene
schattenwelt der sozialen netzwerke
nämlich porträtieren wir diejenigen die
dafür sorgen dass unsere sozialen medien
so aussehen wie sie aussehen
es gibt dort junge menschen die acht bis
zehn stunden vom computer sitzen und all
das aussortieren was wir als user als
nutzer nicht zu sicht zu gesicht
bekommen sollen man denkt dass das man
im netz alles mitbekommt aber das ist
tatsächlich nicht so denn ein großer
teil der inhalte die entweder von usern
gefleckt werden also wir haben die
möglichkeit sachen zu melden die uns
nicht passen auf den sozialen netzwerken
oder von algorithmen also einer
künstlichen intelligenz auch als
verdächtig eingestuft wird wenn das
passiert dann werden diese inhalte an
eine große anzahl an tausende von
content moderators gesendet die müssen
überprüfen ob diese inhalte auf der
sozialen plattform stehen dürfen oder
nicht ob es den richtlinien entspricht
oder nicht
und diese sachen bekommen wir nicht zu
sehen weil sie vor herausgefiltert
werden
und da entsteht natürlich ganz stark die
frage wer entscheidet eigentlich über
die meinungsfreiheit in der digitalen
öffentlichkeit und von diesem prozess
der meinungsfindung der entscheidung
darüber was ist erlaubt auf sozialen
medien bekommen wir als nutzer nutzerin
oftmals überhaupt gar nichts mit und das
ist natürlich extrem spannende frage
wohl mehr und mehr bereiche unseres
sozialen gesellschaftlichen lebens sich
in die digitale welt verlagern und ist
sehr sehr wichtig ist was dort
existieren darf und was unsichtbar
gemacht wird besonders populismus in der
digitalen
welt in den sozialen medien ist
zunehmend stark beschädigt die
demokratie ist der gegner der demokratie
und hat in den letzten monaten oder bei
den letzten wahlen einfach so eine
wirkmächtigkeit was würdest du nach
euren recherchen und erfahrung sagen was
was kann dem so entgegenstehen
zivilgesellschaftliche also erstmal muss
man glaube ich analysieren welche
verbindungen besteht zwischen dem
politischen stil mit populismus und der
erscheinung der sozialen netzwerke und
da ist interessant herauszufinden dass
die sehr viele ähnlichkeiten aufweisen
dass die das handwerkszeug der sozialen
medien den populisten in die hände
spielt denn ein stilmittel des
populismus ist es zum beispiel komplexe
zusammenhänge herunterzubrechen auf eine
vereinfachung und in einer welt in der
man alles in 140 zeichen oder in kurzen
facebook statements offenbart ist das
natürlich das perfekte stilmittel dass
die populisten nutzen können um ihre
meinung in die welt zu tragen
gleichzeitig ist ein mittel der
populisten auch den politischen diskurs
zu emotionalisieren also dem eine eine
eine eine sensations- gehalt zu geben
und das was die architektur der sozialen
medien innehat ist genau dasselbe
je mehr wir effekthascherisch immer mehr
wie ihr sensations- geladene inhalte auf
den sozialen medien posten desto mehr
bekommen wir like views desto mehr
traffic entsteht auf den sozialen medien
und das ist genau das was die politiker
die er in populistischen parteien aktiv
sind natürlich ausnutzen was können die
user die nutzer denn tun um da kritisch
zu bleiben und das nicht für bare münze
zu nehmen also wenn es wie du sagst das
suggeriert dass es eine debatte gibt die
es vielleicht gar nicht gibt oder die
vielleicht auch falsch ist als erstes
müssen wir uns wieder bewusst werden
dass nicht alles was auf den sozialen
medien gepostet wird tatsächlich eine
information ist sondern eine meinung und
dieser unterschied der sonst bei
zeitungen bei traditionellen medien
immer getan wurde der löst sich langsam
auf mit den sozialen medien alles was
ein kommentar ist eine eine private
meinung erscheint plötzlich im gewand
der information die einen
glaubwürdigkeit hat obwohl sie keine
2 quelle prüft obwohl sie eigentlich
nicht mit journalistischen kriterien
erarbeitet wurde
das ist brandgefährlich und da müssen
wir als nutzer eine sensibilität und
eine aufmerksamkeit uns erarbeiten dass
unterschied zu unterscheiden und so
nachzufragen wo hast du die information
her
kannst du eine zweite könnte eine zweite
quelle angeben also nicht alles für bare
münze halten was dort gepostet wird
sondern nachfragen in einen diskurs
gehen die quellen dazu erfordern und
geben auch andere medien nutzen neben
den sozialen medien war auch da
statistiken zeigen dass die junge
generation sich fast ausschließlich über
soziale medien informiert und das ist
natürlich ein extremes problem wenn dort
eigentlich keine informationen mehr zu
finden sind sondern nur meinungen wir
leben in einer digitalen gesellschaft
aber es dort aus euphorie längst
ernüchterung geworden bernhard kürzen
hofft zumindest dass wir digital bald
erwachsen werden bernhard pörksen als
medienwissenschaftler beobachten sie
einen stimmungswandel im digitalen
zeitalter mit blick auf die demokratie
speziellen ja unbedingt also 30 jahre
zurück und zeigt ein netz und open das
netz als die große demokratisierung
maschine als werkzeug zur humanisierung
der verhältnisse und heute wird
allenthalben auch eben durch das netz
das ende der demokratie beschworen
filter blasen echo kann man dass
informationen die neue macht der lüge
der tägliche tram tweet all das sind
gewissermaßen die stimmungs worte der
düsternis die zeigen aus euphorie ist
ernüchterung geworden aus der utopie des
anfangs das historische denken der
gegenwart
hier geht es weiter schwer zu sagen ich
hoffe dass wir im moment etwas erleben
was man eine phase der digitalen
pubertät nennen könnte eine phase der
unreife der überschießenden energie in
der überschießenden aggressionen im
umgang mit den neuen medien
möglichkeiten und dass wir aus dieser
digitalen pubertät herausfinden
da kann nur aus meiner sicht zumindest
bildung helfen
glauben sie dass die populisten mit
demokratie all along vereinbar sind auch
im internet
nun wir sehen auf jeden fall und das ist
keine gute botschaft und keine gute
nachricht dass populistische kräfte die
gewinner sind einer veränderten
medienwelt die schwächung des
etablierten journalismus der aufstieg
der plattform die barrierefreie
desinformation aber auch die möglichkeit
gewissermaßen über einen direkt kanal
die eigenen anhänger auf zu peitschen
all das sind möglichkeiten die
populisten massiv benutzen wenn sie
schon auswege aus dieser aus ihrer sicht
der krisenhaften situation aus meiner
sicht ist der ausweg der und er wird
lange zeit brauchen und viel kraft und
energie und ist von der gesellschaft und
von der politik noch überhaupt nicht
verstanden was meiner sicht lautet die
antwort auf die gegenwärtige situation
wir müssen etwas entwickeln was man
öffentlichkeit bewusst sein
so wie das umweltbewusstsein entstanden
ist als reaktion auf die ausplünderung
unserer natürlichen umwelt müssen heute
so ein öffentlichkeit zum
qualitätsbewusstsein entstehen im blick
auf die vermüllung der öffentlichen
außenwelt bernhard pörksen vielen dank
danke ihm 90 prozent der deutschen sind
heute in der einen oder anderen form
online aktiv und damit ist der
politische diskurs im internet ganz
nüchtern betrachtet eben zu einem festen
bestandteil unserer demokratie geworden
[Musik]